welcome back to poached eggs and today
we've got under menu like some rock work
placement of course restaurant as well
and a couple of thrill rides and they're
scenery which is pretty important as
well I do wanna have a bit more of that
and after that I don't even have any
planning yet because I haven't recorded
the next episodes yet but also that I'll
be doing a little bit more I am thinking
maybe a haunted mansion and maybe one
more attraction if I can fit that in
anywhere and then the roller-coaster
which is still either gonna be a mega
looper or a curse now or maybe something
else but I'm not quite sure and after
that it should only really just take a
couple of episodes until this Park is
finished and to be very honest I don't
quite know what I want to do after that
I might take a very short little break
from architects which actually has a
couple of reasons really since I don't
think I really want to start a new park
yet I think I can kind of leave it over
here one thing which is currently being
promised is that in beginning of next
year there'll be another updates and I
feel like that would be a good time to
start doing some new stuff and maybe
even start doing a series where I just
show off the updates because as good as
I think the updates already are with
images and shifts and stuff like that I
kind of see a bit of a future in there
and also little hidden things in the
updates as well but I am still thinking
about that but in any case I'll be
recording some new either parks or
standalone projects or doing some other
small stuff and architects and I
definitely when a mess in the game
outside of that as well which does make
me wonder when one thing which I'm not
too sure about is in Molokai second and
three my let's play is not my main thing
and in the well it's not my main thing
in a sense that I do much more outside
of the let's play and most of what I do
in rollercoaster go three is not
recorded and should hopefully eventually
get a final video to kind of show it off
quickly which doesn't always happen in
which I'm sorry about
that's the idea at least we just know
what I'm doing in PI texts so far and I
might want to start doing that as well
though I am not sure how exactly I would
go about doing it since you can't
exactly make videos of things in a
cinematic fashion much like you would do
in rollercoaster tycoon 3 so really the
chance is that I'm actually gonna do
that or somewhat slim but I might start
messing with Pocket X a bit more off
screen so that's something that I might
- - but really I do want to start a new
series but not just quite yet and I'm
not gonna immediately after this Park
within one day start another park that's
a little update about that and other
things who kind of keep in mind is that
I am actually planning to buy plan and
coaster and rollercoaster tycoon world
both of them which I should talk about
more later on because this is a park
tech video anyway but that'll be
something that which I'll be quite busy
with as well and I've still got my
rollercoaster in three business which I
want to do from time to time as well so
I don't have too much time to work on it
- I mean University is also a [ __ ] so
that's why also my upload rates isn't
too great so please keep that in mind as
well well I am really the only thing I'm
doing over here is placing down a lot of
grass which I didn't want to do too much
but I am really thinking that at the end
of this this entire little park season I
might make maybe about an hour or so a
little bit of time to spam grass all
around the park so far I do wanna keep
it down I don't know if I've said this
before but the cross and bullrushes and
little little plants in this game at the
moment to cause a tremendous amount of
lag and I don't start risking the
performance of this park too much yet as
I'm still working on the main stuff and
it's still very unfinished but once it's
almost entirely finished I to think I do
in a try placing down many more plants
and get some more detail on the foliage
down so yeah I might actually get some
long grass in eventually - almost
entirely cover up all the ground but so
far I am too
afraid to actually mess with that yeah I
don't really feel too safe doing that
yet the one thing which I am doing here
by the way is that little restaurant
which I had to do I had to redo a couple
times I had some really bombastic
general ideas in my mind but you can
kind of probably tell that I didn't have
a real straightforward planning which is
a bad idea
I do generally I mean really I have to
say if you are planning on building any
building whatsoever make sure you have
some sort of planning at least in your
head don't have to really completely
draw it down like some people would but
at least have some sort of idea rather
than just give it a random go because it
usually doesn't end too well and it ends
like the couple of buildings which I
just had to remove before this one and
this one is really just a very sort of
standard one floor and restaurant
building which can kind of fit in a
corner of something but not but also
kind of look good on its own but I was
really forced to make this simple sort
of building just to be able to actually
fit something in there which I sort of
lights and there was a pretty little POV
of the log flume which is gonna I
actually don't know because I am sort of
did want to make a video at the end of
this park where I shared a POV of every
right but log flumes are a bit of an
issue since they're very slow especially
in this game the lift sale is well
realistically terribly slow so it would
take a tremendous amount of time to
actually make that sort of lift Hill POV
so I might just skip that and have a
couple of areas but um it really just
depends and I don't know if people would
mind having to sit in a log flume for a
while at least I won't sing that I'm in
a log flume which is one thing which I'm
still debating whether I should actually
talk over the overview park video which
I am I am leaning towards I think I do
in a talk over it but I might very well
also just slap some music on it only
thing with that is I do feel it would be
very uncanny to move around with the
mouse while playing some music and not
commentating over it it's it's almost
like
it's it's human playing the game but
then again it's not so in that case I
would probably leave it to still shots
but that's something that that's that's
still very far away that's something I
can probably worry about later on it's
just stuff like that that I am thinking
about already since this park even after
a couple of episodes is already becoming
quite finished and I do have to say it's
it is really a bit of a practice park
please keep that in mind too
there's definitely a lot of room for
improvement I think and some stuff that
I really still want to work on I'm
really happy with some things as well
and it's been a great learning
experience as well but in the future I
would like to move towards parks with
more much more distinct themes I might
eat create a Six Flags like park but I
most definitely probably will focus most
of my things on just scenery parks in
general and I do want to make them much
more heavily themed and actually divided
into separate areas and not like this
park where it is basically one big blob
of stuff everywhere which is realistic
in its own right and definitely a park
that would have probably realistically
grown over time as well but it's
something which I myself sort of okay
with but I'm more of a fan of more
heavily themed
theme parks which will hopefully also be
much easier as one more mods come along
as well maybe new updates from the game
itself which adds some new scenery and
stuff like that is that what I'm waiting
for
well I actually built these simple flat
rides and this is actually very much
stolen I don't know if anybody remembers
this but this is this was some of my
favourite scenarios in roller coaster
tycoon 1 probably many people remember
this since much of the community of this
game is was also playing roller coaster
good one and two but Mel's world had
that little topspin ride with the
opposite cold I also got the drop tower
next to it and ever since that time I
like my brain and just connects these
two rides and sees them as like a pair
of attractions so nine out of ten times
were actually not that often but so many
times I always pair up the top spins and
drop towers that didn't make any sense
so many times I always basically I very
often do team these things up which is
really something that I feel like I got
from Mel's world which was one of my
favorite things ever and it's just I
shouldn't talk about roller coaster
tycoon one but mouse world it was
amazing I don't know if anybody else has
kind of had that but it's one of the
things which I kind of still have as a
little inheritance from my roller
coaster tycoon one years as well as the
fact that I have a tendency to recolor
rides the exact same colors as rides
were Stanley standardly coral-colored
if I can actually talk for a second here
in roller coaster tycoon one which I do
find kind of funny and actually makes me
look forward to actually seeing more of
Rothko's second one in this game but
that's that's um oh my god I'm going
down as path of nostalgia I'm sorry
about that
it's it's one of the appeals to me at
least in this game very much so and the
other stuff is just well it definitely
improves as well but I just feel very
happy inside whenever I see Park tech
doing some stuff that roller coaster can
wand it as well like the ball rushes for
some reason roller coaster in three
didn't have the bull rushes whereas
roller coaster second one and two did
but they were one of my favorite little
plants in roller coaster I couldn't one
and two and almost every Park had them
and they were a very small but actually
quite impactful little plants along the
water side which I'm really happy to
have in this game as well I actually
wonder if it's gonna be in any other
games and it's probably not relevant but
it sort of is for my nostalgia feels in
any case thanks for watching this video
I'm Wade of way out of time so see you
guys in the next episode in which I'll
be starting stuff in the new area of the
park
you